which of the players here confuses you
the most
probably myself
I got confused a lot because I don't
know what happens how did this all
happen none of them confuse me
um I mean I've played them so many times
by now I yeah they don't really confuse
me right now I'm finding it very very
difficult to play to play a ding he's
gotten the better of me recently and
um yeah he's a very very strong player
the camera is a player that I
sometimes didn't understand him since I
have a very best goal against him
probably if there is one player that I
would say about it would have to be ding
now whether that's because he doesn't I
mean he doesn't really speak that much
English or whether she speaks he's quiet
I'm not sure for one name is it will be
Nakamura
who can confuse you either on a
chessboard and in life also so he gets
live one to me is a very confusing
player